à mademoiselle julie tiendront face à
tarbes bonjour j'ai une lettre pour vous
mais dites moi ça ne m'a pas l'air
d'aller très fort aujourd'hui non ça ne
va pas du tout je fais un fichu métier
moi mon facteur vous l'adorez parlons-en
oui j'ai passé toute la journée à
essayer de lire des enveloppes tellement
mal écrite qu'on n'arrive pas à lire la
drees a alors il est certain que ça
renvoie de travail difficiles à 20 qui
le dit vous
voyez me reste tout ça enfin une bonne
dizaine de lettres à étudier moi je
crois que je vais aller m'asseoir sur le
banc a
dit facteurs si vous ne chantez votre
chanson ça vous rendrai molina au nom
non mademoiselle julie salon il n'en est
pas question pour chanter ma chanson il
faut que je sois de bonne humeur alors
aujourd'hui
voilà le facteur a l'air de très
mauvaise humeur bon bah c'est normal
certains enfants écrivent tellement mal
les adresses qui n'arrive pas un livre
skyteam
absolument arriver à les rendre sa bonne
humeur oui tout s'il était de bonne
humeur je suis sûr qu'ils chanteraient
sa chanson très bonne idée ça oui mais
que faire je pense que quelques
attentions qui lui montrent que nous
sommes ses amis lui réchauffera le coeur
tiens moi je vais lui offrir révère
d'orangeade un très bonne idée ça arrive
à moi je vais lui proposer ma chaise
pour poser ses jambes dessus ce sera
plus confortable ainsi allonger le
recteur
mais enfin qu'est ce qui vous arrive
voilà
non mais sinon jamais quand je travaille
facteurs je vous en prie posez votre
jambe sur ma chaise voilà non mais parce
que là vous avez tous les deux un nous
avons vous avez joué de m'empêcher de
travailler nous sommes très bien je
reprends ma chaise reprenez votre pied
et 20
j'ai l'impression que vous cherchez à
rendre le facteur de bonne humeur oui
mais c'est impossible c'est parce que
vous ne savez pas vous y prendre
coffret titre - eh bien tu vas voir je
vais aller lui chiper sa casquette que
tu va le rendre furieux mais nous
regarder
car qu'est-ce qu'il ya casimir pour vous
trois casquettes a disparu la casquette
a disparu mais c'est vrai que ça c'était
pour rentable là
encore j'ai retrouvé ma première songo'o
ma casquette au match gasquet tendrement
mais belle mais qu'est ce que t'as
casimir là là je te reconnais tu es un
véritable ami parce que des nouvelles
comme celle là ça ça donne envie de
chanter par la sueur et bien non je n'ai
pas à musique
[Musique]
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier maçon ou gels au drame
j'aurais pu même être chaude
j'aurais plus intuitive et confiseurs
mécanographe
mais j'ai choisi d'être facteur
quand je suis le droit d'alberto grave
je suis l'ami des jolis mots
amoureux des phrases cv quand je les
emporte sur mon
sous la manche ont voté
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier façon ou
géographie n'est plus maître chanteur
tu aurais pu être cultivateurs
confiseurs ou mécanographe
mais j'ai choisi d'être pacquetet car je
suis ouah de l'orthographe
j'aime les lettres
les écritures guézé charmante quand leur
taux grave faire respecter cela
m'enchante
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier maçon ou géographe georges et pu
même être un champion
j'aurais pu être active at her
confiseurs poum égal au bras mais j'ai
choisi d'être factuel
suit le droit de l'orthographe
dès que comment ce matin
tout le long du chemin
je chante
les gens guette mon arrivée cela
montchamp
[Musique]
à
j'aurais plus a confié sagher muguet
masson rouge et au drame
j'aurais pu même être un chanteur
j'aurais pu être cultivateurs confiseurs
fou mégalomane
mais je choisis d'être pas de faire fort
ce
fait je choisis des tracteurs pour sur
lui mais j'ai choisi d'être un facteur
[Musique]